[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour le weekend Gabriel
on commence avec un concert qui aura
lieu ce vendredi à Guy encours oui et en
tête d'affiche Mathilde le natif de
poissie Alexis HK l'artiste au style
unique sera à la batterie de Guy en cour
demain soir à 20h30 dans ce spectacle
l'artiste à la plume aiguisée jouera son
dernier album bobo playground un album
dans lequel il se moque des bobos et de
sa propre condition sociale de bourgeois
bohemme nous l'avons interrogé sur son
spectacle il y a quelques jours on
l'écoute comme l'album c'est c'est un
assez bon mélange entre gravité et et
légèreté il y a beaucoup de connivance
avec le public
euh beaucoup pas mal de rire quand même
parce que moi j'aime bien mettre une
partie pas standup mais un petit peu
amusante quoi un petit peu amusante j'ai
toujours eu un goût pour les palabres
interminables qui font marrer les gens
euh donc il y a du rire il y a il y a de
la profondeur il y a de la gravité il y
a d'excellents musiciens ils sont trois
derrière moi basse basse guitare clavier
violoncel moi je fais de la guitare ou
pas
euh et donc je je pense que jusqu'à
présent les gens qui ont vu ce ce
concert ont eu envie de d'y revenir bon
si vous avez envie d'y revenir ou de
découvrir rendez-vous à la batterie
vendredi soir à 20h30 déples sont encore
en vente et un autre concert a lieu ce
weekend dans les ivelines mais cette
fois plus sur désert folk et country oui
le court bouillon de Rambouillet vous
propose samedi une soirée country folk
parmi les artistes présents le groupe
route 70 à l'identité musicale pop rock
et jazz manouche ainsi que le groupe
fablouop qui présentera son premier REP
hors du temps et je vous le disais la
soirée se passera au café associatif et
culturel le courtbouillon vous pourrez
donc profiter d'un food truck et de
plusieurs spécialités pour la
restauration on poursuit vos idées de
sortie avec un événement à morpa oui un
événement qui est devenu une tradition
chaque année à morpa le festival amateur
plein feu sur les planches s'achève ce
samedi pour la 9e année le festival met
les compagnies locales de théâtre
amateur à l'honneur ce samedi c'est la
pièce le prénom d'Alexandre de la
patalière et Mathieu de la porte joué
par la compagnie d'interprétation
théâtrale de morpa le syè qui est
proposé aux spectateurs l'occasion pour
les artistes de présenter leur
spectacles dans des conditions
professionnelles du sport maintenant à
quelques mois des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 le village à
vousou les jeux entame sa tournée dans
les communes oui dans exactement 169
jours débuteront les Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique 2024 dont une partie des
épreuves se tiendront vous le savez sur
le territoire de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline à cette occasion la communauté
d'agglomération a créé un village
itinérant l'objectif faire découvrir les
épreuves les sites de compétition ainsi
que de célébration alors plusieurs dates
sont prévues à travers les communes la
première c'est ce samedi à Montini le
Bretonneux et on termine avec une
discipline qui ne sera pas aux Jeux
olympiques mais qui ne reste pas moins
impressionnante le football américain
vous donne rendez-vous ce weekend dans
les yvelin oui l'historique club des
Templiers d'élencour joue à domicile ce
weekend il rencontre les mermidons de
Savini le temple c'est le premier match
à domicile pour les élan courtois le
premier de la saison ayant été annulé en
raison du gel et du froid après une
dernière rencontre marquée par une
défaite les Templiers veulent se
rattraper avec un objectif celui de
monter d'ici la fin de la saison et on
espère qu'ils gagneront leur match merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
idées de sortie